>> I THINK IT IS SAFE TO SAY HOW
THIS GOES HINGES ON THE RESULTS
OF THE ONE-ON-ONE BILATERAL
MEETING.
>> Bret: PRETTY CRUCIAL.
JOHN ROBERTS, THANK YOU.
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT THE REST OF
THE WORLD IS SAYING ABOUT THE
SUMMIT.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT IS LIVE
3,000 MILES AWAY.
>> THE SUMMIT IN SINGAPORE
GETTING THE ATTENTION OF THE
WORLD.
>> THE LEADERS NEED TO BE
CREDITED FOR THEIR COURAGE WITH
WHICH THEY DECIDED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE SUMMIT.
>> PRESIDENT MOON JAE-IN HAS
PLAYED A CRITICAL
A CRITICAL ROLE THROUGH HIS OWN
SUMMITS LEADING UP TO THESE
TALKS.
>> I BOTH EXPECT AND HOPE THAT
TOMORROW SUMMIT WILL DEFINITELY
BE SUCCESSFUL.
>> FEELINGS ECHOED BY MOON IN A
40 MINUTE CONVERSATION WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE LATER WARNED THAT THE SUMMIT
COULD BE JUST THE START OF A
DIPLOMATIC PROCESS THAT COULD
TAKE YEARS.
THERE WERE OTHER WORRIES FOR THE
PENINSULA.
WHAT, IF ANY, PREFERENCE WILL BE
MADE TO AN END TO THE KOREAN
WAR, HALTED DECADES AGO WITH
JUST AN ARMISTICE?
WHAT SECURITY GUARANTEE IS
OFFERED TO THE NORTH BY THE U.S.
MIGHT MEAN TO SOME 28,000 U.S.
TROOPS HERE.
HOW FAR IS THE NORTH WILLING TO
GO TO GET RID OF THE NUCLEAR
THREAT TO THE REGION?
AND WHAT WILL BE SAID ABOUT THE
HORRENDOUS HUMAN RIGHTS RECORD
FOR THE PYONGYANG REGIME.
ONE TIME NORTH KOREAN DETAINEE
KENNETH BAY AS HOPED ABOUT THAT.
>> I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO SEE THE HUMANITARIAN AND
HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES ADDRESSED AT
THE SUMMIT.
>> THERE IS NO ATTENTION BEING
GIVEN BY NORTH KOREAN STATE
MEDIA TO THE SUMMIT ACTIVITIES
OF ITS LEADER, ACROSS THE BORDER
IN SOUTH KOREA THERE IS GRUDGING
RESPECT FOR AN UNCONVENTIONAL
U.S. PRESIDENT WHO HELPED BRING
ABOUT THIS ONE ON ONE SUMMIT.
IN A SENSE.
>> A REVOLUTIONARY?
>> HE'S DONE SOMETHING THAT
NOBODY ELSE HAS BEEN WILLING TO
DO.
>> SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT MOON
ALSO NOTED THAT IT IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BIRTHDAY ON
THURSDAY, AND WHAT A GREAT
PRESENT IT WOULD BE IF THE
SUMMIT WENT WELL.
OVER TO YOU.